obama
all right welcome everybody to day two
of the kyle rittenhouse murder trial we
are back at it again we are right now in
what i believe is just a brief break
this is not the pizza break
um this is not the big lunch break this
is uh the one during which jurors are
asked not to go to the bathroom in the
courtroom um
so let's see uh where to start looks
like we've gotta ban more people it's
been really really bad
um particularly on youtube twitch has
actually been okay to be perfectly frank
it's it's really been fine
but something about this trial is
leading to just horrifying horrifying
people
um
in the chat and it's not it's not good
it's not fun
it's not fun okay but moderators are
gonna be cleaning it up we're running a
clean uh clean stream here
um the prosecution uh so yesterday we
had let's get caught up yesterday we had
jury selection
um
by the way it's funny when people say
we're losing viewers it's like we have
more viewers than we've ever had the
show is bigger today than it ever has
been
um
yeah anybody know by the way what these
closed captions are because there's no
audio like there's nothing there's
nothing going on it's just strange i
don't know where that's coming from
we're also monitoring the court tv feed
as well
which is covering the trial live
um
see look at these look at these uh
closed captions i have no idea what they
are
weird okay so yesterday we had jury
selection
and this morning the prosecution made
its opening statements and what we're
standing by for right now
uh is the opening statement from kyle
rittenhouse's defense which i think is
going to be
interesting nonetheless
we will see i'm not going to prejudge
anything we will see you
they will likely outline the story that
they will tell which
from what we know so far is probably
going to be a combination of
the situation was created by police not
doing their job
and
as a result
kyle rittenhouse had to act in
self-defense
um
that's the gist of what is going to be
laid out i believe
super chats are starting to pour in
patrick says how much do you think
michelle wu wins by yes tonight we're
covering the 2021 election results
there's virginia gubernatorial new
jersey gubernatorial and a whole bunch
of other um
elections including boston mayoral i
think in boston michelle wu who is a
follower of the david pakman show
wow
wow i believe michelle wu
wins by a lot
wins by a lot
that's my prediction we'll see i know in
all seriousness i don't know but we will
uh we will see i want to say a huge
thank you to iran seinen who just signed
up now this is a blast from the past
iran just signed up with the coupon code
please know riot
please no riot this was a coupon code
from when was it
september
18th or october 8 no september 18th when
when the trumpists were supposedly
rioting again and we were like please
don't riot iran re-uh resurrecting that
old coupon code today very much
appreciate that although today's coupon
code is elements of bathrooms i also
want to say thank you to not obsessed
for being today's first twitch prime
subscriber via twitch.tv
slash bezos bucks
which is a really really big uh
big big thing people continuing to
comment on the mustache yeah at this
point
i don't even want to get rid of it
because
i i don't know it's just
i'm just doing it
i'm doing it
um i actually figured out last week i
expressed concerns
about uh
it's weird what the heck
why is the mouse cursor there that's
very strange
it's in a different window
um last week i
expressed concern that i can't seem to
uh shave
without uh cutting myself and i received
a number of different recommendations
the changes i've made since last week
include
before putting on the shaving
gel slash cream using a pre-shave oil i
got one with lavender hello
uh that's been helping also
i didn't realize that down in this area
i actually need to go up to go with the
grain i was just going down the whole
way which shouldn't even be legal and in
fact i think in the dakotas it's not
legal
um and then in addition
i real i was using like a 45 degree
angle with my double-sided safety razor
did some research and i guess you only
want to use a 30 degree angle you want
to use the least angle while you're
still able to shave so three changes
feeling really good at the change about
the changes and barely cut myself
yesterday so very very exciting i want
to say thank you to breezy
and sheldon black
for the new twitch prime subscriptions
numbers three and four today of course
always appreciative of that as we wait
let's see if we can get a sense let's go
to the court tv feed and see what's
going on what's being said so far those
conflicts in testimony and evidence
compared to the videos and the limited
stuff that the state's going to be able
to put forward the jury's going to have
to decide what the truth really
was
and that that's hard
i agree josh this jury does have a tough
job to do would you say that it will
probably come down to whether or not
joseph rosenbaum was still a threat to
cal wrenton house or was ever a threat
to cal rittenhouse
the reasonableness of the threat and how
a threat evolves over time during an
incident is going to be subject to a lot
of speculation and analysis
the defense is going to provide that
kyle rittenhouse was never given an
opportunity to escape and that the uh
assault that mr rittenhouse was about to
receive all right so um monitoring a
number of different analyses and
expecting them to go back very very soon
we'll keep it here for now more super
chats coming in blah says my q anon
friend said there shouldn't be any
elections until it's fixed yeah i mean
what a delusional position stop all
elections
taylor neal
psy d says i feel your pain david i've
fully embraced the beard life a year or
so ago haven't looked back since
and will woodruff says would biden say
let's go brandon in public effectively
troll trumpers by the way keep rocking
the mustache thank you um yeah i
i think let's go brandon should just be
ignored because it's so stupid quite
frankly
um let me get to a few different
elements these are things that are going
to be on today's podcast which i just
finished recording uh youtube clips etc
etc
let's go through a few things first of
all
listen guys
joe biden
was falling asleep during yesterday's
cop 26 opening speeches i don't think
the left gains anything by denying the
obvious he was falling asleep he was
nodding he was dozing off okay his eyes
close and close and close and then his
head actually starts rolling forward
someone realizes it and comes over and
seems to ask him something maybe you
know does he want more coffee or
whatever or maybe just to wake him up he
was falling asleep and i think we look
stupid on the left when we deny what is
taking place
these were boring speeches it was like 3
or 4 a.m body time for joe biden given
the time change
and he's nearly 80. he still has better
positions on essentially every issue
than donald trump and i still prefer him
over donald trump like let's just call
things as they are you know instead of
this um
well
instead of this uh
you you know
idea
that he wasn't actually following he
just he was just he was he was falling
asleep
okay
that's it
um so anyway let's let's just we look
kind of dumb when we deny the obvious
all right so there's joe biden
uh sort of sleepy
that'll be on today's show
this is really funny
this is the
these are fox news's
hold on how can i do this
here we go
these are fox news's guidelines for the
um
annual stockholder meeting
and they're like so strict
it's so funny we're gonna go through
these in detail but fox news has all
these hosts who are just going
completely crazy
because of uh the vaccine mandates
not only does fox have a stricter
vaccine mandate look at the rules like
just to go to their annual meeting
you need
to do an in-person symptom screening
you either need to provide proof of
vaccination or get a 24-hour negative
test rather than like to fly back to the
us you only need a 72 within 72 hours to
go to the fox shareholder meeting if
you're not vaccinated within 24 hours of
the meeting you need a negative test
and look at this
facial coverings
all stockholders must wear facial
coverings while inside buildings at all
times period like just vaccinated or not
you gotta wear a mask
um and
once again
the fox hosts not wanting to talk about
that but talking about how terrible
uh all of the vaccine mandates are that
leaked that's pathetic we're gonna talk
about that
on the podcast today
um
couple other super chats the backwards
mic is freaking me out a little bit
yeah we have i i like to sample
different microphones
uh we've gotta keep banning people bam
bam
bam oh here we go to the defense opening
it's my understanding that council is
going to be showing some videos
to the jury okay
uh these aren't evidence yet i don't
know what's going to be shown oh wow um
and i i think it's an unusual procedure
i've often considered using exhibits
in my opening statement and
i think it's generally accepted that
they're not evidence yet so we can't we
can't be showing them to the jury unless
they're in evidence and we don't have
any of this in evidence yet so i would
object to that fair point he does need
to tell you what he intends to shoot
i got to turn things on here
he does need to tell you what he
proposes to show
and me too
but
the rule does not preclude their use
during opening statement
at all um and uh
what's up mr your honor
first pit the first slide is the jury
instruction
part of self-defense
the second slide
is a picture of joseph rosenbaum wearing
the maroon shirt for identification
purposes
is a video
at the ultimate gas
of mr rosenbaum
having to be restrained
the fourth
is a still photograph
of
mr rosenbaum
walking down the street okay real quick
fry kyle is an insta band moderators
we're keeping it clean on both sides
anyone saying he's a hero we're banning
you know all that [ __ ] and then also
people saying fry fry kyle we're banning
we're doing both we're doing both sides
i don't want any of this [ __ ] in my
stream i'm going to try to find a stream
with higher audio we've pumped up the
audio as much as we can the audio level
on this is a problem i'm going to look
for other streams okay everybody bear
with me oh josh's win excuse me i said
josh see the pbs the rosenbaum is
wearing this is even lower mask
okay so that's horrible starting a fire
at the trailer
that's an interesting accent
that's a wisconsin thing fire a blue
mask
number seven is a picture
from
the ultimate oh and thank you emma
frazzled for the five gif subs gifted
appreciate that commonly been referred
to in this as yellow pants man
kelly and joshua zaminski
showing joshua zaminski armed
with the weapon that was the first
weapon fired at car source number three
number
eight
is a picture for identification of
richie mcginnis
[Applause]
number
eight is a picture of how richie
mcginnis was dressed that evening so he
can be identified in the videos
number nine
is gage gross quits
and his backpack
that's an interesting name gage gross
into evidence
number
10 is the still photograph
of gage groskwitz running down sheridan
road
towards my client
to arming himself you can see him
pulling the gun out of his back
waistband
number 11 is a still photograph of
anthony huber
so what's going on right now if you're
just joining us
the prosecution has sort of
objected
to the fact that the opening statement
from the defense will be preceded by a
video the contents of which are not yet
evidence is anthony huber
holding mr rosenberg
back at the confrontation at ultimate
number 14
is the photograph
of
jump kick man the non-complaining
witness
kicking my client in the head
15
are two close-up photographs taken
from that
of the shoes
of jump kick man
16 is a
photograph of
11 40 pm for everybody saying use the
yahoo feed this is the yahoo feed with
mr bulch and he's confronted by yellow
pants man and three other armed
individuals that evening and those
photographs are blown up in
17 showing one individual with a noose
the other individual with rocks in each
hand
and the other one a picture
of the individual in the blue shirt arm
18 is a video where mr rittenhouse tried
to return to the 59th street car source
and was stopped by law enforcement of
the bearcats
number 19 is a still photograph
taken from
mr rittenhouse
at ultimate as he's leaving with the
fire extinguisher his medical pack and
his gun heading towards car source
three
twenty is the video the what's called
the infrared video
with kelly zaminski joshua zaminski
rosenbaum
my client and richie mcginnis
circled
and identified
1148 is a still photograph of mr
zaminski's arm in the air firing the
first weapon
the first shot
22
is those individuals that same
photograph
um from the video same video a photo
just a couple of seconds i'm shocked at
the rate at which we're needing to ban
people right now it's it's i don't know
that we've ever had anything like this
even on the day of the trump riots this
is it's crazy what's happening right now
is a video taken from and i always
forget this gentleman's name
lucas zanin
from 63rd
street right west of sheridan which
forms the
south
edge of car source
and that's what kyle was running to
there's approximately 100 people there
bashing all the car windows
in there with pipes bats things like
that jumping on the cars
and you hear the first shot which is
and people kind of stop a little bit and
then you see kyle okay here's what i'm
going to do on the volume guys i'm going
to turn my volume down a bit and you
guys can just turn up your master volume
i'm going to just try to stay i've got
this pumped up 600 percent with volume
master so that's what we can do for
today okay and on that video you hear i
just turned somebody
who's been identified as kelly zaminski
yelling get him kill him things like
that he just shot him
25 is gage grosswood's video where he
runs up to kyle it's about five seven
seconds
runs up to him
as he's running down sheridan
at that point mr grosswood is unarmed he
asked kyle what he did isn't it
pronounced gross kreutz why is he saying
gross quids
had to
photograph 26
is for bg on the screen
photograph
of an unidentified individual
in a white
sleeveless or what's commonly referred
to as a white beater shirt
hitting mr ray
in the head knocking his cap off
and then right after that
you see the next photograph from that
video
of
circled
mr
huber picking up after a skateboard
which he had used to strike
my client in the head
the next photograph is a still
photograph
of
an individual running up to kyle as he's
on the ground there are several
individuals in that photograph one of
those individuals
being jump kick man approaching from
kyle's right
and the next photograph is him
kicking kyle in the head
right 30 is the picture
of the close-up of that
and the shoes
31
is a photograph
of
mr huber
striking
kyle rittenhouse in the head with his
skateboard
held by the trucks in his right hand
what
the trucks of the skateboard
uh you know do i look like ice
skateboarding
okay the wheels
are wheels
the reveals with his right hand while
he's grabbing kyle's gun his bare hand
touching kyle's gun with his left hand
the next photograph is
depicting jump kick man getting up from
the ground
mr huber with his hand once again on the
gun going forward
and still having a skateboard
33 is a close-up of that photo
34
is
you can see the strap on mr
rittenhouse's gun being pulled taut mr
grossquitz running into the frame from
the right of the frame
next is gage grossquitz
standing in front of kyle rittenhouse
with his hands up kyle does not shoot
next gage grow squids
lunges forward with his right hand
pointing directly and that is when the
shot is fired
and then there's a picture of kyle
rittenhouse on the ground individuals
approaching him
one with a pipe one with his hands up he
backs them off does not fire
11 51
kim
video
trying to turn himself into the kenosha
police department and turned away and
the final is a photograph
from the antioch police department
surveillance cam
at
1
20. if you're just joining us this is
defense counsel listing the images and
videos that will be part of something
they will play leading into their
opening statement i guess we don't need
any witnesses we've got the whole trial
there i thought the opening statement
was supposed to be a summary
of the evidence not the evidence itself
this this is i think we're up to 41
videos and photos that are going to be
uh seemingly introduced through the
testimony of attorney mark richards this
is a highly unusual procedure judge
we will both sides will have the
opportunity to call witnesses
to talk about these things um we will
have an opportunity in closing arguments
to characterize these things
um but to
to give the the jury
let's see what the judge decides i like
this argument that these things are the
all the evidence or even that a lot of
these things are relevant um but for for
the opening statement to essentially be
the entire defense case
uh and all the evidence we're showing it
to them is highly unusual um i took the
approach in my opening statement and i
guess i was uh
not pushing the envelope as far as i
should have
but it's always been my approach that i
will
describe
what i believe the evidence is going to
be
but i'm not the witness i'm not uh
giving them the evidence that's what the
testimonies for we've had a stipulation
as to the authenticity of what do people
think is the judge going to allow this
video or not they're admissible in
evidence it does not mean we're
conceding relevance on to those things
and i anticipate that there will be some
arguments as to the relevance of a lot
of these things we've already had some
arguments about some of these things
so you know you stress
oh god uh it took five minutes for him
to list
all those things let alone what it's
going to take to actually show them and
play them for the jury um so i i think
as a general policy your honor and i
understand it's not necessarily the law
but witnesses should be presenting
evidence not the attorneys in their
opening statement
so i i object to this procedure i think
it's
it's overly long
it's duplicative of what the evidence is
going to be there'll be an opportunity
through witnesses to present all of that
i think council should be describing
what he thinks the evidence is going to
show that's appropriate
but showing them all the evidence
this way why do we even need witnesses
at this point let's just i'll get up and
i'll play all the videos i want to play
they'll play all the videos they want to
play and then we'll just be done without
any testimony let's see what the joy
this trial should work so i don't think
this is a proper procedure your honor
and i do object to it okay
uh well
first of all are you going to be able to
authenticate each and every one of these
all of these come from exhibits
that have been agreed or stipulated to
the authenticity
and uh they're all
going to be relevant
they all are relevant they've all been
just trust us judge let us show the
video first
i've already heard about uh by and large
um you know the standard is not what you
did or what you can do or could do
the standard is what the law allows and
i can remember
oh boy
studying this 50 years ago that this was
an acceptable way with judicial
permission to make an opening statement
we see it more in civil cases than in
criminal it's on
it's not cus customary in in uh yeah
it's criminal cases but i've seen it
done by europe
uh so and i have to say that you're
right this is a record number in terms
of the numbers
but uh on the other hand there's record
there's a large number of crimes being
charged and separate acts that uh
are being assaulted this attorney's
level the acts that the state alleges
were unlawful and the defendant's claim
of self-defense so
um
given what that they do appear all to be
relevant and that they've been
agreed as authentic then um
i don't see any reason that i should
interfere with
and also you can't call the victims
victims mr finger making makes a good
point in reinforcing my comment that
this is supposed to be brief and
informative
so keep it i think i'll be any longer
than him
your honor
bless you
all right anything else yes your honor
one of the motions in lemonade filed uh
which was not objected to by the defense
is that there be no reference to any
pending uh or prior criminal uh cases or
convictions with regard to joseph
rosenbaum
um the parties are aware the jury is not
uh that there was at the time of his
death a pending criminal case between
joseph rosenbaum and his girlfriend
carrie ann swartz oh no and there was a
bond condition that prohibited
mr rosenbaum from having contact with
her they're going to impeach
one of the people involved here with
unrelated complaints and proceedings now
i made a reference in my opening
statement to the fact that mr rosenbaum
saw miss swarth that night and was
basically was not allowed to stay with
her or did was not uh able to stay with
her that night so he left her residence
and i purposely worded it that way your
honor because there are many reasons why
someone may not
be able to stay at someone's residence
it could be because of a bomb condition
it could be for a myriad of other
reasons
it's my understanding from an off the
record discussion with council that he
intends to go into this he believes i've
opened the door to it i wanted a
pre-trial ruling from the court on this
issue we got one and i'm now raising it
because uh if it's going to be mentioned
in the opening statement i think this is
the time to address this issue rather
than in the middle of an opening
statement so i'm bringing it back up
again i do not believe that my statement
opened the door to it and frankly my
statement is not evidence um so i don't
know they can really open the door
anyway but by and large i was very
careful in the way i worded that and i
don't think it opened the door i don't
think regardless this is a relevant
issue
for this trial mr rosenbaum's conduct
with regard to ms swart has nothing to
do
with what was going on on the street
that night so it is completely
irrelevant and i would ask that the
court reaffirm its prior ruling on my
motion eliminating
your honor he can't have it both ways he
can't go and say he was at the house and
he couldn't stay there and not why can't
we tell the jury why because there was a
no contact order it's not appropriate he
thinks he didn't open the door but he
danced through the door is this guy
canadian the hospital got out of the
hospital he was in a mental hospital
that's a joke i know guys on the witness
stand and we're not going to get to ask
that
i mean that's insane i was very careful
about the word hospital your honor
i believe it was actually saint luke's
and racine
which is a medical facility it is not a
mental institution this wasn't mendota
or winnebago or something along those
lines
and frankly i'm not even 100 certain why
he chose to check himself in but again
whether or not mr rosenbaum needed a new
kidney or needed medications for mental
illness or was going to have his blood
pressure checked has nothing to do
with the the events of this night and
frankly it's just a backdoor way of
attacking his character and suggesting
to this jury that somehow because
there's going to be an allegation from
the defense that he had some sort of
mental illness that
that had something to do with i'm gonna
tell you guys this is not looking good
for the prosecution none of this is
looking good for the prosecution that we
can we can go down that line and we can
talk about whether mental illness
contributed his behavior what was his
diagnosis what medications were he on we
could open that door and go all the way
through it but that's a mini trial on an
irrelevant issue
and i
if it's going to come in there's a way
to get it in through an other axe motion
which was never filed by the defense and
i certainly have not opened the door
when i talk about the word hospital this
could be covet treatment it could be a
kidney transfer it could be anything it
does not open the door and again i was
very careful in the way i worded that
your honor you know if i start talking
about his medications or i started
talking about you know seeing a
psychiatrist or something like that
that's different hospital is a very
nebulous term that could mean
a myriad of things you know help me out
here
i thought when i read the pre-trial
motions and i know there were a series
of them on which there was
agreement so i probably
may not have the best recall of those
because i didn't have to put too much
thought into it but
i thought that the references are the
statements which were attributed to um
mr guys i think i fixed the audio issue
there was some kind of weird compressor
on it i think i just fixed it uh you're
telling me that
he was there was also discussion about
hospital
no or there's there's no video or
statements or audio of mr rosenbaum
talking about the hospital the only
relevance it has here all right i think
we're good now so sure it was there is
oh there's i think we fixed the
testimonial uh
are we going to hear testimony that he
made statements that he had just gotten
out of jail that day sir he's better
than i am okay my respect your statement
on your
on your
uh opening statement was
and and i will tell you this i wanna i'm
gonna ask you to try to reconstruct it
for me or if necessary i'll have the
reporter read it but
i don't i don't recall the exact
statement i do know that i thought at
the time i'm surprised he's going into
this
because it may trigger a response so
what's what what exactly did you tell
the jury what i said your honor is that
that mr rosenbaum had gotten out of the
hospital that day and was carrying
around a plastic bag right which is the
kind of bag that hospitals give you to
carry around your personal belongings
the only relevance that has to this case
is that i just wanted to get i just
wanted again sure statement yeah and i
was doing that because the bag comes in
and that's that's the only thing i
understand relevance okay now
and you also made a statement about his
being with
the person by whom he was allegedly
bound not to have contact that's true
and do we know the exact scope of that
order
i i believe it was a straight typical
no contract typical no no no we can look
it up your honor yeah yeah well
uh what did you say about it what did
you say about it
what i said is that he had seen her
after he got out of the hospital right
that he couldn't stay with her and so
then he left and essentially came
downtown
and miss will testify and she will talk
she couldn't stay with her i'm sorry why
did you say that he couldn't stay with
her i said that because it explains why
he didn't why he left and came downtown
he's got a hospital bag your honor
there's
it's a little unusual i think for
someone to be released from a hospital
have a bag of their personal belongings
go to their girlfriend's place and then
continue to walk around with it
that's that's a little unusual we know
what was really going on and by the way
how do we know that
he had been there and had left is she
going to testify yes okay yeah and so
she's going to talk does the judge have
any memory about the things that have
been argued about this before i mean
just like everything about this is
bizarre and it looks very good for kyle
rittenhouse senate there's been some
allegations out there that this is a
molotov cocktail or it's got chemicals
in it or some it's got something that
could cause the defendant harm it had
toothpaste mouthwash a water bottle in
it that's that's that's the narrative
did the mouthwash have fluoride or not
by the house concerned the relevance is
not something i want to talk about now i
want to talk about what you said and why
he thinks it
is worthy of response he's
misrepresenting the facts of the case of
the jury by saying hospital when it was
a mental hospital mr binger knows full
well
he had gotten out for a suicide attempt
so and
let the jury know what type of hospital
it was why he was acting the way he was
he was not acting appropriately that's
part of the defense
and then he goes and says can't stay
there why can't he stay there because
there's a court order that says he can't
he wasn't supposed to go there in the
first part
oh my god
and if he was on trial for violating his
bond then we'd have that trial but he
hasn't been tried or convicted of that
because he's deceased
but
your honor
and by the way we have the bond
condition here it's no contact including
the residents electronic or third party
with carry-on swart and the park ridge
inn which she uh stays there and they
had been staying there together until
that criminal case started so you know
if if we want to charge mr rosenbaum
with violating his bond uh what good
would it do is deceased but yes that is
true but again it it doesn't make him a
criminal on this evening it doesn't make
his behavior that's the point help
explain any of that stuff
i don't
think
as far as your opening statement
you need to respond to his statement
about the hospital
i'll have to separately decide
at a later point as to whether
whether he had been hospitalized and for
what i don't know if that's admissible
or not i suspect that it is not right
but
i'll keep an open mind
uh and um
as far as here is not being there or not
supposed to be there
again i'm not sure that i want to hear
about that in your opening statement it
seems like the right thing but um
uh again i'll hear you later as to why
do you think that it violates hipaa
giraffe and badger my client traveling
here from out of bounds and he's trying
to say oh he had a good excuse for not
being at home he couldn't stay there
that night well the jury should know why
he couldn't stay there well i don't know
if he can't stay there he can't stay
there she could have kicked him out
because she didn't like uh
he is having a hospital bag i don't know
i'm not sure it's necessarily relevant
he was very
like like the defendant was not
supposed to be allegedly and uh we'll
let them play out but you don't talk
about those two things in your opening
statement anything else do not talk
about it
so now they are going to bring in the
jury the opening statements from defense
counsel are going to start i want to say
thank you to c missile for the twitch
prime subscription number 16 today also
a huge thank you to bo lungberg
subscribing today on my website with the
coupon code felony 21 new member number
17
as the jury comes in here
i just want to remind you guys we're
doing multiple streams today second day
in a row of the written house trial i
will be back tonight at 8 pm eastern
time with the results from virginia new
jersey and a bunch of different mayoral
races i would love it if you supported
the work we're doing um and the triple
duty discharging our duty on the
multiple streams plus the podcast get a
membership on my website
joinpakman.com it's dirt cheap and if
you want to make it even dirtier i'm
sorry even cheaper
use the coupon code elements of
bathrooms to save 69 percent i will
thank everybody who signs up to the best
of my ability to pronounce uh the names
of the folks who sign up kyle
rittenhouse looking a little tired
here and we are going to see now
the start of defense opening statements
defense opening statements
the jury of course kept off camera
as is typical thanks to jakey stark for
grabbing a twitch prime subscription
very much appreciate that jakey
super chats continue to come in they'll
be up on the screen
the bringing up of a mental hospital
especially due to suicide seems like a
disgusting attempt to weaponize existing
prejudice absolutely
absolutely defense attorney seems to
have a lot of aggression
absolutely
absolutely
all of these things true
uh this is defense counsel this is the
defendant kyle rittenhouse
i'm not sure who this woman is here
maybe another attorney
thanks to clinkhammer for grabbing a
twitch prime subscription number 19
today very much appreciate that
all right welcome back uh
what did i say
10 minutes right
judicial time
um
when you're dealing with what do we got
five
six lawyers in the room what do you
expect
all right let's go mr uh
also thanks to alpha omega for the sub
ladies and gentlemen of the jury
good morning still for the next 10
minutes
this is my opportunity to tell you and
show you what i believe the evidence
will show
you've heard the state's opening
statement and now i will give mine we
have two very
different
outlooks on the events of august 25th of
2020
kyle rittenhouse was present
in kenosha wisconsin
on the evening of august 24th he stayed
at his friend's residence
dominic black
he saw in the live streams and things
like that the events
of the 24th
he
saw a car source
number one as i refer to it
the one that's on
the east side of sheridan road
burned all of the automobiles
burned
destroyed
he saw the looting going on he saw the
other businesses burnt down and
the next morning he went down
to downtown kenosha
to look at the damage he stopped
any
helped clean up
at the old ruther high school i think
it's called something else now but when
i was around here it was called ruther
before that bradford
and
he saw that he met one of the owners
from car source and they talked and they
decided that they would offer their
services him and dominic black and nick
smith to help protect the property
of car source ladies and gentlemen the
evidence will show
in spite of what the media and public
statements and things like that have
been the evidence will show that kyle
rittenhouse
had strong ties to kenosha
his father lived in kenosha
his mother lived in antioch illinois
kyle worked here in kenosha county at
the rec plex in pleasant prairie as a
lifeguard
he went downtown to clean up the
graffiti him and nick left there and
they decided to come back that evening
and help car source
lot 2 which is at 59th and sheridan and
initially car source 3 at 60th in
sheridan and
when they were
doing that
they met other individuals who had come
to town at the urging of websites and
things like that and then just a general
i would say distaste for the destruction
and
those guys from the west bend area ryan
balch lakowsky joanne fiedler
agreed that they would all help protect
the car source line he's basically doing
community service actually they went to
the lot at 59th early in the evening
and
what will end up being
you will see the events of that night
unfold in video
and still photographs
but ultimately what this case will come
down to it isn't a whodunit when did it
happen or anything like that
it is
was kyle rittenhouse's actions
privileged under the law of self-defense
that is that the defendant believed that
there was an actual
or imminent unlawful interference with
his person
the defendant believed that the amount
of force which he used
or threatened to use was necessary to
prevent or terminate
the interference and that his belief was
reasonable
you as jurors will end up looking
at
it from the standpoint of a 17 year old
under the circumstances as they existed
on august 25th 2020.
and
mr binger makes a big thing
out of
kyle rittenhouse was the only person who
shot somebody that evening
true
mr rittenhouse
was the only person
who was chased
by joseph rosenbaum that evening but was
he the only person chased would be a
better question
and what's important in this photograph
is one it will allow you to identify him
throughout the course of trial notice
the belt
the baggy lengthy jeans
and there will be a fair amount of
testimony i'm sure regarding the maroon
shirt he's obviously
currently wearing it
mr rosenbaum
was
at a location
and mr rosenbaum
had
along with other individuals started
a dumpster on fire
and when somebody put that dumpster that
was very close to a gas station out
mr rosenbaum became enraged
[Music]
i'm going to go back
let's just sound on
that's just a brief snippet of that
interaction
and
he was
it looks like colin kaepernick is on the
screen here of the prosecutor is that is
that kaepernick right there can anybody
tell
which you'll see in the course of trial
oh i guess not
holding him back trying to stop him from
getting at an individual who is dressed
with a baseball cap
an ar rifle
and long pants
excuse me short pants short who looks
very much like kyle rittenhouse
here's mr rosenbaum
during the evening
him and his friend or associate joshua
zaminski
had just come from starting a trailer
on fire
he arms himself
with a chain
and goes up and down
sheridan
road
carrying this rather heavy chain used to
tie down equipment
next is a still photograph
taken from the ultimate gas station
where he was shouting shoot me [ __ ]
shoot me [ __ ]
at a black life's rally
black lives who is that behind him
joshua zaminski
the evidence will show that mr zaminski
also named his alec blaine and mr
rosenbaum are together
throughout the evening
and joshua zaminski plays a central role
in this scenario on august 25th one
creating chaos and havoc with mr
rosenbaum
and two
more importantly when we finally i like
that pronunciation of havoc havoc
is the individual who fires the first
shot that evening behind kyle
rittenhouse as he's being chased
by mr roosevelt
here's a picture with two circles
mr
rosenbaum and mr zaminski starting the
trailer on fire on sheridan road along
with a dumpster
you see the photograph judge second one
circle
testimony will show that that is in fact
mr rosenbaum wearing a blue
mask texting very strongly the judge
and carrying a bag which i'm sure there
will be
much
testimony about
other individuals
in this
once again
mr zaminski
in the photograph taken at the ultimate
this is a still from one of the videos
you'll get to see
is mr zaminski
armed with the weapon
that he ultimately fires at the car
source three judges trying to remember
whether he normally gets two or three
spice level from the indian place he's
opening ordering from right now on her
hand
with a big heavy flashlight
as you can see there was no need that
evening for a flashlight other than it
being a weapon
count two is an individual by the name
of richard mcginnis
he was a reporter
covering the riots in kenosha he had
covered the riots in portland
minneapolis
and he will tell you what he's called in
the witness stand by either the stare or
myself
that
he was dressed like this
that night the black t-shirt with the
white back
the helmet on his head
and he had interviewed kyle rittenhouse
and talked to him
and mr balch and rittenhouse were going
to go out and see if anybody needed
medical attention that evening
and richie mcginnis was going to follow
along
he will testify
that he goes out with them
and eventually they have an interaction
with the individual
who we refer to as yellow pants man
this
is gage grow squids
the individual who is the victim
or excuse me the complaining witness in
count five i apologize
and did you guys see that even the
defense counsel is calling him a victim
even though the ju they didn't want that
the evening
filming
even defense councils like this was the
victim
ten
excuse me the next photograph
is
the evidence will show gage grow squids
running
down sheridan road
and you see his hand
going into the back
of his waistband pulling out a firearm
to arm himself the evidence will show
through testimony of an individual by
the name of nathan de bruyne
that that yellow could it be argued that
that opens the door to referring to the
deceased as victims
down sheridan road
mr groskwitz is not in any danger
kyle rittenhouse has already told him
that he's going to turn himself into the
police
yet he arms and continues with the mob
to attack
this is a picture of anthony huber the
individual who attacks
my client as he's laying on the ground
after being kicked in the head by jump
kick man
with his skateboard
he hit him with the skateboard as he was
running down sheridan road and then as
he's laying prone on the ground he comes
in for another hit on his head
and then
grabs
kyle rittenhouse's firearm to try and
take it away from him
the next photograph is a picture
to look at the whole skateboard the size
of that skateboard
the trucks of that skateboard
ladies and gentlemen i would love to be
able to hold up that skateboard in front
of you
as evidence today
because then you could see it you could
see the weight and the heft of what a
skateboard is and what that skateboard
would do is somebody takes it in their
hand and swings down on somebody's
shoulder head and neck
trying to separate the head
from the body as mr huber did
but i'm going to object to the argument
here your honor this is this is strange
beyond a characterization of the
evidence and it's mr richard's
interpretation
as an argument
you'll see the photographs you'll see
the videos
right you'll get to make the decision of
what anthony huber was trying to do
the skateboard doesn't exist
ms giddings his girlfriend in spite of
repeated requests by detective howard
refused to produce it that's what the
evidence will show
mr huber at the ultimate gas
holding back
mr rosenbaum who is
ultimately
the individual who lit the fuse that
night
man i refer to as
jump kick man or the non-complaining
witness
kyle
is laying
on the ground after being knocked to the
ground by an individual hitting it out
of the rock anthony huber hitting him
with the skateboard
and jump kick man comes in
kicks him square in the face
with his black boot
close-ups of that
and as he's kicking him in the face kyle
fires two shots at that individual he's
not hit
he gets up
and he runs away
into the night
never to be seen again
never coming forward to identify himself
as a victim
complaining witness or otherwise to law
enforcement
we look for him the evidence will show
the state looked for him the evidence
will show those are the big players in
this case but ultimately what you'll end
up having to decide
looking at all the circumstances of that
evening
are the events that occurred over really
a
brief
15-minute period but more importantly
three minutes
the police for everybody thinking that
we're able to see the
we wouldn't you're not missing anything
it's it's one line there there's nothing
there's nothing we're not
we're just not able to see what they're
referring to i know the top of it is on
the screen here but everybody relax
going
in
a southerly direction down sheridan road
there's no statement that if you go in
that direction
you can't come back if you have business
in that direction
what
kyle
an individual by the name of ryan balch
followed by richard mcginnis go down
there
sheridan road
and at 11 40
they have a conversation yelling medic
you'll see the videotape of this event
kyle's got his medical bag his gun
and he comes upon these three
individuals
and the individual in the yellow pants
accuses
kyle rittenhouse of pointing a laser
sight from a gun at him kyle shrugs it
off does not want confrontation with
these individuals does not point his
firearm at him and he leaves
why does he leave because he doesn't
want trouble
these are the three individuals
who are with yellow pants one individual
is carrying a noose i don't know what
that's for
the other individual the testimony will
be from kyle rittenhouse and richie
mcginnis had rocks in his hands
and then
the blue shirted individual was carrying
a nine millimeter firearm richard
mcginnis will tell you
about
the marauding nature of these
individuals
he was so intimidated by them after kyle
walked away that he had to give up two
white claws to him to settle him down
and some cigarettes so that he
would be able to leave them
kyle from there realizes he's been
separated from mr bulge
he goes over to the ultimate gas station
looking
for
mr bulge and is unable to find him
what happens next is he attempts to get
back to car source
at 59th and sheridan road
this is kyle on the right coming into
the frame
video from roughly
[Music]
[Music]
business they don't let him pass
he goes back to the ultimate gas station
and a few
minutes later
at approximately
11 45
he receives a phone call
from dominic black
dominic black informs him the evidence
will show
that
they're breaking windows and starting
fires down a car source three go and
stop them
he asks an individual for a fire
extinguisher
and
asks the individual to go down to car
source 3 with them the individual gives
him
the fire extinguisher but does not go
with them and kyle heads down to car
source 3.
he doesn't know that mr rosenbaum is
down there he's been asked to go down
there by nick smith
he heads down sheridan from 60th walking
to sheridan in 63rd where the car source
is
that's a picture of him from a video
leaving the car source at 11 46 p.m
approximately he has his firearm and he
has as you can see in his other hand a
fire extinguisher to put out the picture
the fires
and that are being started down there
this is an aerial photograph that the
state is referred to in its opening
and it's actually
started to roll and you'll see circles
in here there's kelly zaminski
in the green
lettering
and that's a thermal energy and
image excuse me
i don't think i get started
it starts very slowly
and guys again the super chats are not
blocking the video it's it's
it's one pixel like there's nothing you
would see additional there's a guy's
head blocking it everybody relax they're
deliberately not showing it to us we
just see that little top inch there of
that screen
beginning to chase my client
oh court tv is showing it let's see
image excuse me beautiful
here we go
people are labeled richard mcginnis
richie mcginnis and they head down
you see mr rosenbaum come around
from hiding in the cars
beginning to chase my client
you'll see the flash of the firearm
from mr zaminski and you'll see the
flashes
of his first shots
i am not responsible for cutting this
video i don't know how it got
the way it did chopped up that's the fbi
up in the plane that took this video
but it's very telling because you'll see
this 100 times i'm not going to go
through it again for an opening but
you'll see it
that the individuals are heading down
sheridan road
and
you'll see this
mr mcginnis is now over here
go
and hide right in this location
you'll see kyle come
into this area and pause
where mr and mrs ziminski are
and you'll see
in this car
there's a fire that's starting to see
how it's bright
and they go
kyle runs in this direction trying to
get away from mr rosenbaum
ladies and gentlemen kyle rittenhouse is
under no obligation
whatsoever to retreat
from
mr rosenberg
he does
he runs away from him because he doesn't
want the confrontation he doesn't want
trouble
which makes no sense
with what the state says about him
hunting or chasing him down
he's trying to get away from the
individual here we go you'll hear
testimony not just from kyle rittenhouse
but
bulch
mr bulch
about joseph rosenbaum stating
to kyle
and to ryan bulge in each other's
presence
if i get either of you two alone i'm
going to he doesn't want trouble
but he went from a neighboring state as
a 17 year old to quote defend businesses
when mr rosenbaum is shot
in the car source lot 3
there's been a gunshot behind kyle
he turns to address mr rosenbaum of this
firearm
mr rosenbaum is not deterred
he continues to run
you'll see that on numerous videos
closing the distance mr rosenbaum could
have stopped at any time
mr rosenbaum
is wearing
that maroon shirt
on his face
as a mask
covering up his identity
because he
wants to steal
my client's firearm and use it against
him to carry out the threat he had made
earlier that isn't just the word of kyle
rittenhouse made up after the fact
you'll hear the testimony of richie
mcginnis who was close that evening he
was following behind them you'll see him
on the video
he'll testify to you
in court he did not
feel endangered
he was doing his job
he will testify
that joseph rosenbaum
let out
as he put it one of the scariest screams
i ever heard
oh boy
so the audio just went
out let's i guess for now
go back here examiner
he breaks every
frame down he knows how much each frame
takes
he counts the frames and he comes up
with that time
okay next photograph let's go back see
if they have the photographs here
first of a second we're back from first
shot
to last shot
those shots will be put those
measurements will be put forth by dr
john black who's a certified video
examiner
he breaks every
frame down he knows how much each frame
takes
he counts the frames and he comes up
with that time
next photograph
11 48
that's car source three
you see
an individual
right
here with his hand
in
the air
the evidence will show that it's mr
zaminski
this is mr rosenbaum in full stride
running after kyle rittenhouse this is a
still from a video
and you'll see a lot of videos leading
up to this
you'll see a video i believe it's from
corey elijah where he's confronted by mr
rosenbaum
and he doesn't want a confrontation and
he goes you'll hear it on the video the
video is not
showing
that confrontation but you hear kyle's
voice and he goes friendly friendly
friendly
he thinks because he's giving medical
attention and helping people out that
people don't have an animosity against
he's wrong
but that's the belief in his head and mr
rosenbaum chases after
and i believe
that the state will want to say why did
he go down there he went down there
because nick smith asked him to
why didn't he keep running
one you don't have to run but two
i'll show you
a video from
63rd looking back
onto the car source lot
taken by an individual who will testify
and his daughter
next photograph
circled again
zuminski with the arm up rose and bomb
and full stride chasing and an arrow
pointing to kyle
this is the video from 63rd
and sheridan road
i don't know why the audio goes out on
the court tv feed every once in a while
oh my god i am
you'll see that whole video during the
trial
the individuals were at car source the
rioters
destroying all those vehicles as kyle
was running from mr rosenbaum
he did not want to run into those
rioters who were destroying all that
property that did not belong to them
you hear the first gunshot the evidence
will show mr zaminski
you hear four shots in quick succession
the evidence will show that is
kyle firing at mr rosenbaum as he's
trying to take kyle's weapon from him to
use against him
you hear three more shots in quick
succession i don't think the government
will have any dispute i don't think the
evidence will dispute those three shots
are from another person who's in the car
source lot
firing
for some reason
he was never identified never arrested
this will show kyle running
back to the scene of the shooting
it will show
i think the evidence will show
why kyle rittenhouse didn't stay and
render aid for mr rosenbaum not that
he's under any obligation to do that
but sometimes
discretion is the better part of valor
okay
the individuals who are yelling
he just shot him shoot him and you can
see one of them with a gun
mr and mrs zaminski
he begins running down sheridan road
he's not taking his gun
he's not threatening anyone as he's
running down sheridan road
he's running in a southerly excuse me i
always get my directions diffused a
northerly direction
from 63rd towards 60th
what is that 60th the evidence will show
that is where law enforcement is
and that's where somebody would run
to be protected from a mob that wants to
kill him
the evidence will show
this next video
taken
from gage groskwitz
he runs up to kyle at this point he is
unarmed
kyle does not point a firearm at him
does not do anything to dissuade him
from approaching him
you'll hear on the video the exchange
and you'll see it
hey what are you doing
you shot somebody
who's shot
who's shot stop hey stop him
you see him running with the gun at the
ground
away from mr grosskids mr grossquitz
came up on kyle got very close did kyle
point a firearm at him did kyle shoot at
him no all he wanted to do was get to
the police but the mob is closing in
of which mr grossquitz is a member
the first individual
runs up behind kyle
and hits him in the head
with his hand or hand with a rock in it
this yellow circle shows kyle being
knocked a bit of skew but more
importantly
his hat being knocked off he's run all
this distance his hat stayed on his head
the government doesn't want anyone to
think that he's being attacked or hit
this still photograph shows that his hat
is being knocked off
that's the first
blow to mr rittenhouse
he continues to run
the testimony will show
that
these individuals
are running up on him
what's important in this photograph the
evidence we'll see
show
is
on the left
the testimony will be
that
mr huber
is picking up his skateboard
why is his skateboard on the ground
because he has taken his skateboard and
swung it at kyle rittenhouse's head
for the first time
hopefully each of these assertions they
can actually prove because you know
still image is
okay
fall down
the two red
marks are one the individual who struck
him first
and jump kick man closing in
kyle goes to the ground
this is a still photo from a video
you'll see
what's important here the evidence will
show it's an individual
kyle's on the ground within
two feet
kyle points the firearm at him
does not fire the individual backs up
he's no longer a threat kyle does not
discharge his firearm
the next picture
the unidentified complaining witness
jump kick man
kicking kyle in the face
behind
jump kick man
is
huber
now he's picked up his skateboard this
is a photograph from a different angle a
different individual
and you see him running in kyle's
direction
there's the boot right before contact
those are the boots that struck kyle
rittenhouse in the face
here is the photograph
mr huber's bare hand
on the skateboard
holding the trucks bringing it into
contact with the back of kyle
rittenhouse's head
jump kick man still has not even gotten
completely on the ground and where is mr
huber's hand
and it's important here ladies and
gentlemen it's a bare hand grabbing his
gun the state will produce evidence i
believe that there's no dna on the gun
you must not have touched it ladies and
gentlemen there's video photographic
evidence of him touching the gun
next
the bare hand pulling the gun towards
him
jump kick man getting up to run away
you can see a close-up the bare hand on
the gun kyle rittenhouse flat on his
back in the most vulnerable position one
can be in
there the strap is pulled tight mr
huber's trying to pull the gun away from
kyle rittenhouse as he's laying flat on
his back
kyle's afraid he's going to be disarmed
and shot with his own weapon the
evidence will show he fires one shot
striking mr huber in this photograph
just entering from the right
the evidence will show us gauge gross
quits
one hand
a phone
one hand a firearm
here's gage groskwitz
with his hands up kyle rittenhouse does
not fire
look at the distance between them
huber's skateboard has not even hit the
ground yet that's how fast all these
things occur
mr grossquitz does not stay in that
position or back up
he moves in on kyle getting closer
pointing the gun
almost directly at his head
as the state said
he's like this
but look at where the gun is going
the gun is in the circle
it hasn't got directly to pointing at
kyle's head but it's going there kyle
fires once
hitting him
another individual approaches
after gage groskwitz has been shot
puts his hands up
kyle rittenhouse does nothing
in that
events
in event number two
the whole event from first shot
with mr grossquitz excuse me jump kick
man coming in and getting the two shots
to the time gage grow squids is shot in
the arm
is about five seconds
you'll have exact times of those shots
how fast it occurs
and
after the shooting that evening mr
groskwitz was interviewed
he told law enforcement
his story of that evening
the one interesting detail he forgot to
mention
was that he was armed
when he got shot
he told the police
that he
had lost his gun as he was running down
sheridan avenue he didn't know that
there were people out there like him
videotaping and photographing everything
he had a gun in his hand and that's why
he shot
his statement says
that the reason he went into the fray
was because he had to stop anthony huber
from beating kyle with the skateboard
at 11 51
kyle has gotten up there are individuals
around
who are
in that area who've come at him he's
pointed his firearm back them off
and he continue continues in the
northerly direction down sheridan road
to 60th
[Applause]
up
[Music]
imagine finding out this is what your
kid was up to can you imagine
you see kyle with his hands up approach
the police car to turn himself in the
evidence will show that the police told
him to get away from the car and go home
the police say that they peppered
sprayed kyle kyle didn't get hit with
the pepper spray he's not disputing that
they might have shot pepper spray at him
that's why he backed up so quickly
he finally makes his way
to car source
two back at 59th
meets up with dominic black the
individual who sent them down to car
source 3
tells them about what had happened
dominic black i believe will testify
that
he saw him
he was white as a ghost sweating like a
pig
and he was explaining what happened
saying he had to do it it was
self-defense
they talk about going home to antioch
dominic black takes them home
they leave
about 10 to 12.
and at 1 20 kyle rittenhouse and his
mother are walking into the antioch
police department
turning themselves in
to the police which is what he wanted to
do here in kenosha but the way kenosha
was that night with the police
department surrounded by fence and
things like that he couldn't
he turned himself into law enforcement
he said from that day what he did he's
made no
bones about that
he acted in self-defense ladies and
gentlemen the evidence will show
that his actions on august 25th of 2020
were reasonable
under the circumstances as they existed
that night
being attacked by mr rosenbaum the
evidence will show and the law is clear
he didn't endanger those other
individuals
the government can refer to him all they
wish
as an active shooter the only person he
had shot
was joseph rosenbaum who had made
threats to kill
had made numerous statements about
ripping people's hearts out he wasn't
afraid to go back to jail
and nathan de bruyne will testify
to some of the actions of mr rosenbaum
that night and he'll testify
and it was one of the more telling
statements i thought in a statement
if there was trouble that night joseph
rosenbaum was there
and that's ultimately who visited
himself upon kyle
rittenhouse the evidence will show he
thought probably
that he could get that gun from kyle
rittenhouse probably he was wrong
kyle rittenhouse protected himself
protected
his firearm so it couldn't be taken used
against him or other people from mr
rosenbaum who had made threats to kill
and the other individuals who didn't see
that shooting
attacked him in the street like an
animal wow it's not even that he's not
guilty according to these lawyers he's
almost like a hero
thank you mr uh
richards let's break for lunch folks um
i'm gonna take let's go back to our
other feed
we have this
uh blower up here which uh
on occasion i've uh well i used to and
it's gotten progressively worse over the
years in terms of its
enormity and intensity and
but it controls the entire building
so i can't shut it i can't ask them to
shut it down because it has control over
the water of the air throughout the
entire building and it's tied into what
they did to the ceiling here
in
1965 or so
all right with that please don't talk
about the case during the break
uh and is it unrealistic to
set a tentative start time of about
quarter after one
but if you folks want more
um that's okay just let it let me know
if you want more time
uh and then we'll use this as a trial
for the future
if you decide you wanted to go less time
too we could do that but
right now we'll aim for 1 15 and
any questions
okay thank you very much
so the jury will now exit they're going
into lunch break unclear if they have
pizza sandwiches quiche or something
else today uh opening statements we've
heard from the prosecution and now we've
heard opening statements from the
defense team we're going to talk about
all of it they're going to be back
momentarily for more
um
i can't thank enough as we wait for them
to move here the folks who have been
supporting the stream today
i really really really want to thank
people who just got memberships on my
website matt allen
just signed up on my website mike leone
is a new member
paul herbig and andrea sullivan thanks
to both of you
r.j kwik as well as alexandria bain
have just signed up that's six people
uh putting us at 28 for the day
we've been uh streaming every day of the
trial so far
okay looks like they've cut audio for
the time being i would really really
appreciate it if you signed up on my
website joinpacman.com
we do have a coupon code available that
code is elements of bathrooms we really
are primarily supported by the work that
that uh um by by the memberships that
you get on my website really appreciate
everybody signing up today's a great day
to do it i'm gonna be back tonight to
remind everybody
second stream tonight it is election day
2021 and there's a bunch of different
elections tonight which i will be
covering we will have live results
virginia gubernatorial and others and
others and we will even i think what i'm
going to do is i would love to open
phone lines tonight
wherever we end up today we're at 28 if
we say let's say we get to 50
i'll start at 50 tonight just to make it
even more likely that we get to 100 and
open
uh phone lines
we are banning an historic number of
people
primarily on youtube but some on tv as
well people are getting timed out people
are getting permabanned it's actually
crazy what's going on um
let me see if i if anybody believes they
should be unbanned
we can take a look
now it seems like they've oh no six
people want to get unbanned all right
let's do this real quick um
a lot of people are asking to be
unbanned let's i don't have my mallet
with me right now
um
let's see user bob juice under frank
just typed boring in all caps about 50
times and they were banned then their
unban request is kyle rittenhouse is an
american hero
that's a perma-ban very very easy
um user raving mage
said it was full-on self-defense and was
banned and then said i did nothing wrong
uh yeah i mean it's just like
that that's
we're banning people on both sides with
that stuff
um
i don't know i mean it's like
i don't know
let's pause that one for now
um
yeah some of these
a couple of these i'm gonna unban
because they are just expressing
opinions about the case
uh
yeah some of these i'm gonna unban like
it's fine if you just are expressing an
opinion
we're not gonna do like the free kyle
kyle is a hero stuff
um
yeah i'm actually unbanning quite a few
yeah maybe i'll even handle these off
stream some of these are complicated
we're all it's kind of it's all it's all
kind of hectic um
i know people they're trying to
everybody's trying to make the best
decision they can at the time
um okay jen here and two guys one shovel
our new twitch prime subscribers numbers
29 as well as 30 and i really do
appreciate that people asking what's the
best coupon code i think the best coupon
code is this one elements of bathrooms
which is a 69
off code it's a really good code
i feel good about that code
okay
let me get to a few other things that i
had just a few little things different
people
um might be interested in
this was as many of you know andrew yang
will be appearing on the david pakman
show
soon um this was an interview that was
uh
done yesterday this was peter bogosian
um interviewing andrew yang i got a
little bit of a shout out let's take a
listen
that's been of interest to me so the
right wing had a feeding frenzy on this
story and so this is partially how the
game is played
so
i put out a series of tweets
here's a problem i'd like to talk about
so the president of portland state
university said that racial justice is
the highest priority of the institution
fact check that you can put a link to it
and i i'd like to have a conversation
with people on the left not a debate
i'll even you know it's no gotcha i'll
even tell you the question beforehand
should racial justice be the highest
priority of a public institution
nobody would have that conversation with
me
cnn nbc msnbc opb which is the oregon
public broadcasting npr
the oregonian nobody nobody wanted
nobody on the left would talk to me so
here's how the game is played so
something will happen
the right will have a feeding frenzy you
go on right wing shows you you you
express interest you even call on the
phone or you'll send emails or you make
it public to your twitter uh please i'd
like to have this conversation with you
nobody on the left will have a
conversation with you i shouldn't say no
i want to take that back one person i've
had conversations with him his name is
david pakman he's the only person on the
left who'd speak to me david david's
david's a good guy yeah he'll he'll
actually have a conversation with you
all right so that's cool um
andrew yang is gonna be on
with us soon and i think that that's
gonna be cool
um another little shout out
this is the new uh leftovers podcast
with ethan klein and hassan [ __ ]
and um got a little shout out there as
well take a look at this so strange to
see it's like dude i just wish you would
have more
left uh
left leg you're talking about rogan here
it's just it's annoying because i would
like to watch him engage in a
conversation with somebody that you know
actually knows these issues yeah i mean
he he'll have a little abby martin on
every now and then liberals
um he'll have every martin on every now
and then he has kyle kalinski on every
now and then david pack when he's the
last time he had any of those guys on
like i don't think i like him it was
actually relatively recently who which
one i like pac-man all right so a little
bit of a shout out there from ethan
klein
um
very very exciting
and then let's see what else i have for
you guys oh thanks to david montalbano
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code elements of bathrooms
number
31 today at joinpackman.com
also thanks to cyclone force for the
twitch prime subscription number 32
today folks the code is working the
coupon code is working please don't mess
with me it is working um one other
element here that i wanted to play for
you guys
this is the epitome or the epitome as i
once heard read off of a teleprompter it
was once pronounced epitome it's epitome
i i present this without comment okay
take a listen to this this is on the
podcast today very very important clip
what's the most important issue in the
governor's race here in virginia and i'm
not
an issue in the governor's race here in
virginia getting back to the basics of
teaching children not teaching them
critical race theory
and uh and what is critical race theory
well i'm not going to get into the
specifics of it because i don't
understand it that much but it's
something that i don't
the what little bit that i know i don't
care for and i know nothing about it and
i couldn't be more against it have you
heard that that you don't
like i'm not gonna
you know
i don't uh
i don't i don't have that much knowledge
on it but it's something that i'm not
that i don't care for guys i've never
tried sea urchin in my life
but everything i know about it i don't
like
and i'm not caring for it right now
i've never read anything
by john le carre but i'm i think it's
terrible i really do it's just it's
terrible at least he's honest about his
ignorance exactly let me see if there's
any other interesting clips the good
liars do really really great stuff so
there's this one
um
let's see what this one is these guys do
really good stuff when do you think
trump is going to be back in office
are you guys pro-life pro-choice i'm uh
it's a woman's body it should be her
choice
okay i have nothing to do with it i mean
who am i to tell a person to do
something they think it's a mistake i
mean personally i wouldn't do it or she
wouldn't do it
it's about individual freedom exactly
exactly which is really you know that
that is a very like republican woke way
of looking at things to quote
out here yeah exactly all right thank
you so much really really appreciate it
so you're seeing that that's an
interesting viewpoint we're seeing here
um which is a little at odds with some
of the other [ __ ] we've seen all
right that's kind of interesting
uh let's see this one gone away like
american values are out the window all
respect you know what it's called
there's no respect what does the shirt
mean again this means [ __ ] joe biden
okay cool is this your son it is oh cool
it is how old is he he's 14 14 all right
it's like ever since
[Laughter]
yeah
uh wow
that's um
that's that's something else right there
irony is dead it really is thanks to
ryan jones who just signed up on my
website using the coupon code
elements of bathrooms let me see if i
have that one i actually don't know that
i have that on my panel today we're
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers
and what happened if you watched the
election i was called by the biggest
people
saying congratulations political people
congratulations sir you just won the
election it was 10 o'clock and you
looked at the numbers and i'm sure you
felt that way
this election was over and then they did
dumps they call them dumps big massive
dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania and uh uh
all over uh if you if you take a
right exactly okay good so we've gotten
that out of the way and we can all be
really really really thankful for that
okay let me we we have a few just a few
minutes left here until they resume i
will i will acquiesce i will do a few
voicemails for you guys we did get
a very very
significant number
of voicemails overnight including about
yesterday's coverage of this whole thing
but i've got some older ones as well
let's just see what we've got okay
let's see what we've got here
hey there my name is jason i'm calling
all right the audio quality is too
horrible on that
hi david it's uh vernand calling again
from toronto i called you last night on
a different topic i was just listening
to your
commentary on nina turner losing her
her uh election race
and you did speak on a couple of
uh theories on maybe on the left that
we're saying
uh because she's more black or too black
and then you said you found that
not
doesn't make any sense because you know
chantal brown is also black
i i i would be interested to see the
doubt you know what this this is a
two-month-old voicemail i'm sorry three
months old voice voicemail we're just
going through the voicemail
um and that it just i don't remember
exactly what i said i can assure you it
was nothing racist
um
yeah
i love your show
um i'm a
67 year old white female
um but i'm wondering why
all your colors seem to me to be males
i'm not even choosing anything do not
the females call you yeah i mean shows
like mine skew mail in terms of the
audience overall we we believe the
audience is like 70 70 30 male
but on both tick tocks
and instagrams
we have a much more even split um where
it's much more 50 50. i like this caller
or what to do but um
you're they all seem to be males
explain that to me thank you all right
very nice i like that very nice uh
very very nice lady
let's see what else we got
hey david i
had a question regarding
vaccinations and
backstabbing children in
divorced
families
so i have an ex-husband
who
is just
he's not smart basically okay and he
does not want our son to be vaccinated
he's 12. does not want her son to be
that naked he's insist he'll become
sterile which i know is absolutely
stupid becomes sterile i think she said
and as a pharmacy technician i also
and
and
inform
staying informed
with not just your show but overall
watching um
getting my information my information
from many places
okay yeah so that wasn't whitney it
sounds really bad your ex-husband sounds
like a real real problem
um and i don't know
what
to do about that that seems like a major
issue
david what do you think about um
religion in terms of
um having like the right kind of
philosophy to deal with
economics i don't really look to
religion for economic uh
economic ideas quite frankly
hey david it's snug
wrangler
i'm tired of the word progressive
meaning that you're normal
on social issues
okay you're not a bigot towards
you know lgbt
and stuff like that
but
you're not um
you know the word progressive isn't
being used to describe someone who's
you know either a social democrat or a
democratic socialist either way they're
not you know economically progressive so
i'm tired
of the word progressive
not meaning that
i
okay
i don't even know what to say about that
okay just checking just checking i guess
if the voicemail
works
uh
all right
hey dave it's oz i just want you to know
that
i am incapacitated
right now okay all right i'm gonna get
away from that um oz does have a
drinking problem it's not a joke it's a
medical issue
um
[Music]
hope oz gets uh
gets the help he needs
david there's something i'm i'm
listening to one of these voicemails
that you played and the fellas just
doesn't have the correct information
about the back scenes yes that you're
i'm sure you were right that's
absolutely true
and and i'm seeing other videos where
people are complaining that they're
losing their job that they can't work
unless they get the vaccine can i point
something out please please i want those
people to remember something
the right wingers in this country have
pushed and pushed and pushed dating all
the way back to the 50s for this right
to work law
scenario in all 50 states
and under that rule
the employer can fire you for any reason
at any time and even for no reason at
any time right
you hate unions you've done everything
you can to eradicate and take power away
from the workers all these years you've
done this and now you've got the
temerity to sit there and cry
because your employer has said guess
what you're either going to take the
vaccine or you won't work here
sir sure
exactly grow up
pull up your mind panties real nice and
tight and own what you've done
i used to be a union worker i used to
have a good living i used to have
benefits i used to have a retirement but
no you free trading
uh to hell with the worker anything for
cheaper labor republican party took it
all away from us every damn bit of it
and you get that you're still not happy
with that you're the same people that go
out and
complain about this guy's on fire
illegal aliens but yet who do you employ
and pay him under the table
and destroy our
social safety net you don't contribute
to the tax base you don't contribute to
workman's comp you don't contribute
tonight this guy should have a show
and you know the employer the employees
don't have the money to pay it on their
own
so if you're one and you're sniveling
enough
grow up and own what you've done over
the last since 1952
when the first right to work state
happened that was alabama look how good
they're doing
you and your trickle-down garbage i'm
sick of you people grow up take the
vaccine i'm extra military you want to
know how many shots i've had in my life
i used to walk down the line and get 12
at a time
no you're not a scientist and you'll
never know and all this crap you keep
buying from q anon you need to pull your
heads out
but i am thoroughly pissed about the
idea that you want to sit here and blame
these employers after everything you've
done to labor oh since 1950 and probably
before that
you people are insane i'm sorry david
but it burns my cookies
uh and i appreciate it
have a good day that's a hell of a
caller that's a hell of a caller we got
to clip that i want to say thank you to
brandon foster who just signed up on my
website using the coupon code elements
of bathrooms and his new member number
34. also a huge thank you to steven
danks who just signed up with the coupon
code
sinks and showers which also is a really
good one let me see if we're looking
very strongly at sinks and showers new
member number 35. uh also over on twitch
no nobody over on twitch all right
that's okay uh very much appreciate that
let's look at a few super chats cause
super chats have been uh going crazy
tyler says mr pacman sir oh hold on
sir i don't know mr pakman sir could you
please have that caller on the show more
yeah let's actually see
let's see if
he's left other voicemails let me do a
search
yeah so that same caller called in in
january let's listen to what he had to
say in january
yeah hey mr paglin and i'm calling you
from south carolina i was watching this
segment on the frank lutz um
um saying he was doing there with all
those different trump supporters
and one person in particular brought up
right at the end of their comment about
talk radio as being one of their sources
for news
and a lot of people do this in this
country and i still think that's the
reason the republicans don't want to fix
the infrastructure because the longer
you keep these people in your cars the
longer you've got to brainwash them and
a lot of these stations are the ones
that get their traffic that's an
interesting idea that's that's a very
very interesting idea and then this
caller also called in last week let's
see what he had to say last week
yeah hey david this is ike i'm calling
you from charleston south carolina i
just got a bent somewhere and i figured
i'd put this out there to you maybe you
could discuss it a little bit
but i don't understand how it is through
all the media and every all the
commentary and what's been going on
that the democrats can't get it done the
democrats can't get it done and don't
get me wrong mansion and cinema both
deserve a swift kick in the pants
particularly manchin in his corrupt
family his wife and his daughter as well
but we're losing sight of the fact that
the republicans have done absolutely
nothing
and are continuing to do absolutely
nothing where's the blame put on them
yep all right so this is a very strong
caller i like this caller very much
appreciate it new caller welcome to call
in anytime
um this man is my spirit animal give
that man your show
david like what is your stance on like
callers like calling in repeatedly to
like ask like a random like question
about like
like yeah dion says those good liars
interviews are a perfect example of what
david should have on his show should be
live with ability to interact through
super chat exactly
mr pakman love your moderation strongly
sir
calling him kyle to emphasize youth
i went to college in kenosha and he
looks like a straight townie
i'd be in jail if i recruited a minor to
protect my business to protect
businesses with a firearm
all parties in the attack could be
guilty
placing yourself in an antagonizing
position and baiting an attack doesn't
make it self-defense that's what the
jury is here to decide very much so
i'm confused if a group of people are
attacking me and i have the means to
defend myself aka hitting me in the head
with an object what am i supposed to do
let them hurt me i'm confused
more complicated than that why did a
miner have a gun alcohol and cigarettes
out of state
when do you think jump kick man will be
introduced into the mcu
david did i miss why we can't see the
evidence oh okay this is so this is a
lot of earlier stuff
jason says five dollars for david
another five to get that man some fresh
cookies
yeah burnt cookies are no good i want to
say thank you to lynn riley lynn just
signed up on my website using the coupon
code better21 and his new member number
36 i appreciate that
uh people asking
oh no not again uh how do you make an
amazon prime account a twitch account
you have to connect
amazon prime to twitch okay it's very
easy to do just google
connect amazon to twitch
connect amazon to twitch
you go to
hold on what is the exact link
uh link your amazon and twitch accounts
here i'll pay i'll paste the link
i'll paste the link in twitch chat here
okay you just connect them
here's how it works if you have amazon
prime
you get a free twitch prime subscription
every month does not renew automatically
you can choose to use it on any twitch
channel you want could be this one could
be another one don't let it go unused
because then you just leave money with
jeff bezos okay i just pasted the link
i'll paste it again i'll even paste it
over on youtube in case anybody on
youtube has amazon prime it's possible
that somebody does
um
okay
thank you very much all right let's do a
few more
um voicemails
see what we got here
hi damon hey man
can't do it nope audio quality is too
low
hey david i live in central
massachusetts worcester county
and i noticed right after massachusetts
lifted the mask mandate for vaccinated
individuals
nobody was wearing a mask anywhere i
went into a home depot walmart you
couldn't see anybody wearing a mask in
any location
and i found it kind of weird made me
look around and say wait a minute is
everybody here
vaccinated
and i think the reality is the situation
is
people just didn't want to wear masks so
the moment the government gave you an
option not to wear the mask
everyone just took it whether they were
vaccinated or not yeah of course yeah we
knew that that was going to happen uh of
course of course of course of course
um
let's see listen to a couple other
voicemails
let's see what we got here
yeah what's going on pacman is uh mike
from largemouth new york listen first
time caller
man that mike lindell interview that was
crazy i really wish he took the 25 000
bet i would have loved to see
uh what would happen and whether he
would have taken it uh but unfortunately
he did it
uh great content great show uh thanks
again keep it up
all right thank you very much appreciate
that see what else we got here
uh
hey david i just wanted to say congrats
on your success uh i don't know how much
you feel like you're being successful
but
i just realized
when i was watching your private videos
that i'm a member of
you have like 1.4
000 people that watch it
and i remember the days where it was
like
400 people
and you had so many members
so i just wanted to say congrats and uh
i hope it goes too big for you to handle
bye
thank you i appreciate that yeah it's
tough i'm always thinking of the next
thing to be honest so i uh that's i was
just talking to some people about this
it's hard for me to really celebrate any
success because i'm just kind of
thinking of the next thing but it's an
important thing to do i want to say
thank you to factor v mutated arpine
eyes of the bluest skies and whoopsies
all for grabbing twitch prime
subscriptions numbers 37 38 39 and 40.
also thanks to mitchell lansky for
signing up on my website using the
coupon code elements of bathrooms you
are new member number 41
which i appreciate quite a bit
a few other super chats christian says
it's worth noting you need to be on a
desktop version of twitch to use amazon
prime you can't apply it with the mobile
app i didn't know that
thank you christian
thank you
um don't burn ike's cookies
good on you for allowing straight up and
down opinions it plays into the false
right narratives that dems are out to
end free speech yes millions believe
that huge fan yeah i don't have a
problem with people expressing an
opinion i mean listen hell i think kyle
rittenhouse is going to sail to a not
guilty verdict on the on the homicide
other people are saying you can use
prime on mobile okay i don't know the
answer to that thank you
um so listen if you're expressing your
opinion that you think kyle um
rittenhouse was acting in self-defense
by the letter of the law or just that
you think that's the way the trial is
gonna go that's not a problem we're not
gonna ban people for that
it's not a threat we just don't want
nuisances in the chat
okay
thanks to satan 77 and 49er fred for the
twitch prime subscriptions numbers 42
and 43.
um
oh you know what okay i i'm being told
that this they're actually not even
going to resume in 20 minutes that it's
going to be more like 40. so since we've
got a second stream coming tonight we've
had the opening statement from the
prosecution the opening statement from
the defense i've got an entire other
stream tonight and i've got to plan
tomorrow's show between now and then so
i think i'm going to cut this stream now
we'll keep this at 43 and pick it up
there tonight okay i'll be back at 8
eastern we're going to have virginia
election results new jersey election
results um
a bunch of mayoral races and a bunch of
other electoral elements tonight okay so
thank you all for joining me here for
this stream
second stream tonight the trial will be
back in about 40 minutes for those who
want to continue watching i'll see
everybody in a few hours thank you